Först kanske man ska prata lite om, jag har ett problem.
Steg två, jag har hittat lösningen på mitt problem.
Steg tre, hur funkar den lösningen?
Steg fyra, rekommenderar att testa det här, det var skitbra.
Steg fem, nu har jag ett e-bill redakteras också om det är så, vad ska jag?
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har renda språk.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Jakob Vixelius från United Influencers till Podd och Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena Jakob.
Tjena.
Vi har ju haft kolossala problem att få till den här inspelningen, inte för att vi egentligen borde ha det utanför att du tog fel på dag och jag tog fel på tid.
Så att, uppenbart två stressade människor som inte sköter sånt här så bra.
Exakt, vi får se hur det här går om vi lyckas utföra.
Jag sa det innan, vi får hoppas att vi sköter våra bolag bättre än vad vi sköter våra appointments mot varandra.
Men nu sitter vi här i alla fall och det ska bli lite gött.
Kan vi inte få en liten, du behöver inte gå igenom hela din barndom, en liten känsla för vem Jacob är.
Ja, jag är ett sex år gammal, jobbar som vd för United Influencers.
Koncernen egentligen som består av United Influencers i Sverige, Norge och L-magazin i Norge också.
Jag är uppväxt i Kalmar, bodde i Stockholm i större del av mitt vuxna liv.
Och har varit i den här branschen egentligen i drygt tio år.
Varför har man ett bolag som har den uppdelningen?
Jag fattar att ni har influencer där och influencer där, men varför har ni en tidning också?
Är inte det lite skumt?
Ja, det är en bra fråga.
L är egentligen världens största modemagasin, fortsatt, vi finns i över femtio länder.
Det är ett licenserplägg som ögs av flanska legadärer.
Det här licenserar man ut till massa olika aktörer i världen.
Någonstans finns det en medvetenhet också om att magasinbranschen förändras ganska radikalt.
Det sker en digitalisering, det sker också en koppling i mångt så mycket till influens-
och marknadsföring och så klart också affiliatmarknadsföring och så vidare.
När vi fick den här licensen för drygt åtta år sedan så var man det ut i efter några aktörer som kunde ta en liten annorlunda take på traditionell publicering egentligen.
Vi driver ju magasinet i traditionell bemärkelse men också i en lite modern retattning.
Vi ger ut tio magasiner om året, vi driver en sajt som heter LOLO.
Vi driver L-galan i Norge och lite andra event.
Men tänker också väldigt kreativt kring hur vi jobbar med kreatörer och så vidare.
För att locka till oss nya målgrupper och så vidare.
Är det skumt att ha det ansvaret på den norska marknaden?
Du är ju inte norsk tänker jag.
Kan man som svensk komma in och ha den feelingen?
Man vänder sig rätt fort och Oslo är ju ganska nära Sverige.
Det är nog det lättaste landet att jobba som svensk.
Sen finns det ju större kulturskillnader än man kanske tror.
En marknad med ganska mycket flexibilitet.
Ändå också Modemagasin och det premiumsegmentet tror jag också är en intressant målgrupp på norska marknaden.
Man har en ganska hög snittinkomst och så vidare.
Det finns ju någon sorts fördom om att norrmän är rika och lata, att de inte är så framåt för de har redan så mycket pengar.
Är det skillnad att jobba med influencers i Norge och i Sverige?
Jag vågar inte svara för hur hela samhället fungerar i Norge, men oavsett hur världen stadet ser ut så går det alltid att hitta folk med starkt driv och folk som vill genomföra saker.
Det är samma med personalen på åretid.
Vi har ett enormt bra team där borta som är väldigt trivna och som skapar jättefin tillväxt för äldre i Norge.
Hur det ser ut i övrigt låter jag osäkta.
Det var ett diplomatiskt svar men vi förstod alla andra meningen av vad du menade.
Jag tänker att L-magasinen har väl folk ändå någon sorts förståelse för vad det är.
Jag tror att de flesta har sett den tidskriften i någon tappning.
Men vad gör United Influencers?
Vad är det här andra bolaget eller vad man ska säga?
Det är ju själva huvudbolaget som man säger.
Det är klart att båda bolagen ligger med varmt i hjärtat.
Men United Influencers är ju vårt egna varumärke så att säga.
Vi har varit i influencerbranschen sen dag ett brukar jag säga.
Även ur ett globalt perspektiv har vi väldigt tidiga med att professionalisera influencermarketing.
Sen finns det alltid utmaningar med att vara först.
Jag brukar jämföra lite med om man ska bygga första elbilen.
Det betyder billigare att bygga elbil nummer två färre än konkurrenten och var de som gjorde det först.
Det är klart att tittar man tillbaka på influencerbranschen för drygt tio år sedan, då fanns det inte så jättemånga profiler.
Det fanns inte så många plattformar på det sättet utan när United Influencers startade så var vi ungefär i den här övergången från att bloggarna började gå över till Instagram och skaffa sig en publik där.
Så det är den stora grejen idag att det finns så enormt mycket fler profiler.
Det finns också fler plattformar och varje plattform har ju sin unika nisch så att säga.
Men är ni ett team av influencers eller är ni någon sorts samlingsplattform för dem eller vad är er roll i den?
Vi startade faktiskt som en agentur för drygt tio år sedan och representerade några av de största profilerna i Sverige och Norge.
Men det har egentligen aldrig varit vår mening att bedriva någon agenturverksamhet.
Jag har alltid ansett att det finns en viss lojalitetskonflikt när du på ena sidan ska representera en profil och på andra sidan jobbar med kundens return on investment.
Men det är inte sagt att inte alla ska vara nöjda i ett samarbete.
Men vår ambition idag är att vi konsulterar våra kunder för att få så bra återpåverkning som möjligt när de satsar på influence marketing.
Och vi får göra det och så anlitar vi profiler som underkonsulter egentligen.
Vi har ingen representation av profiler, utan vi kontaktar profiler direkt eller jobbar med deras agenter.
Det är egentligen upp till profilen om de lär ha en agent eller inte.
Så vi representerar inga profiler, utan vi är helt oberoende.
Det ligger väl i linje också med hur vi tycker att branschen utvecklas, att det blir en mycket större mångfald av profiler och större mångfald av plattformar och hur man bygger lignal.
Så det är egentligen helt kundlojala när man säger så.
Okej, så ni jobbar med företag.
Jag försöker bara bena ner.
Jag är inte så inne i denna världen.
Ni jobbar med företag och så sätter ni upp kampanjer.
Är det så?
Eller liksom, så här ska ni jobba med detta och sen söker ni upp influencers som passar och ni förhandlar och ser vart de passar in och vad de ska göra.
Är det så liksom?
Ni liksom projektleder företagens snack med människor som ska synas.
Om man målar med flera penseldrag så är det ju så.
Vi gör en Moos-analys av alla våra kunder.
Kunderna kan ha olika behov och vissa är väldigt kampansspecifika.
Man vill göra det här enskilt, stora satsningar under begränsade perioder.
Många idag har mer av en av och sånt strategi.
Det är klart att även om vi inte representerar några profiler så har vi ett enormt stort nätverk av profiler.
Nu jobbar vi inte enbart i Sverige utan vi paketerar i regel nordiska kampanjer men vi gör också en hel del kampanjer ut i Europa och en del i USA också.
Vad man kan säga om våra kunder är egentligen att antingen är man ett bolag som inte kan inflationsmålarkting eller som man kanske inte har den expertisen och det använder man då som en förlängd arm.
Det kan också vara så att man har personer som är duktiga på inflationsmålarkting internt men man kanske inte har det surserna att bedriva det här utan man vill ha en förlängd arm med den bemärkelsen att vi vet vad vi vill göra men vi behöver någon som gör det.
Sen kan man katastrofisera kunder att antingen är det ofta kunder som befinner sig utanför Norden som vill in på den nordiska marknaden och har vår lokalexpertis eller så är det nordiska bolag som vill ta sig ut från Norden men har en lokal kontaktnation så att säga för det.
Jag fattar, okej.
Du sa ju att ni har varit med ett tag eller ni var en av de första in i, skulle vi kunna ta någon sorts liten trip down memory lane här från att folk skrev, jag tänker att bloggar var väl på något sätt typ först och man kunde skicka ut ett paket chips och så skrev folk 15 inlägg om det och så var det världens bästa arrow i.
Och sen till att, ibland får ju vi sådana här meddelanden att hej, kan ni ge mig 75 000 så gör jag en story för er.
Alltså, lite, lite, hur har det här gått och hur har Influencers, bara en liten historia liksom om Influencer branschen.
Lite som jag var inne på tidigare, när man backar bandet lite senare så var det färre profiler som var ganska stora på olika plattformer, mycket Youtube, blogg och sen Instagram också.
Anledningen till egentligen att vi kände oss tvungna att ta en viss representation av profiler i början, det var för att det fanns en sådan enorm bokkunskap.
För det första så visste man knappt vad begreppet betydde.
Profilerna hade ju jättedålig koll på sina kommersiella värden, någon skulle ha hundratusen för ett inlägg och någon skulle ha en t-shirt för samma jobb egentligen.
Och likavillts nog är kunderna för att det här var lite PR-branschen som jobb tidigare, att man skickade ut produkter, jag kom ihåg att jag pratade med en profil som hade ett extra rum i sin lägenhet bara för gratisprodukterna som kom.
Och i regel så hämtade man inte ut produkterna heller om man var kanske en större profil.
Det var också väldigt mycket smygreklam på den tiden i form av att det fanns inga riktiga regleringar i att ta emot ett PR-paket i utbyte mot det du ska göra att inlägga, men då måste du också markera att det här är reklam.
Ta emot det men det är utan krav och då kanske du inte behöver göra det.
Mycket sådana frågor.
Sedan började man ju se de här bolag som till exempel Daniel Wellington och Nacre, de här bolag som var väldigt tidiga på införingsmarkning, de började få en extremt talande investment på att jobba med införingsmarkning och där tog det såklart lite fart.
Begränsningen då, om jag refererar till mig själv när jag jobbade här, det var att det blev en ganska stor obalans på marknaden.
Det var ganska många bolag som ville jobba med influencers.
Det fanns inte så många influencers att välja på.
Det saknades också nischer.
Idag finns ganska mycket nischer om man tittar på TikTok och YouTube framförallt, men även Instagram och det gjorde att alla bolag jobbade nästan med samma profiler ett tag, vilket gjorde att det blev väldiga variationer i resultaten som blev också av de här samarbetarna.
Det kunde hända att vi hade ett inlägg som genererade en miljon i försäljning, där man kanske hade lagt 50 000 kronor för att göra inlägget, medan någon blad en miljon och fick ingenting tillbaka.
Vad som har skett framförallt med branschen är att utbudet av profiler har blivit mycket fler.
Det har blivit många fler profiler, vilket demokratiserar också prissättningen lite grann.
Jag tror faktiskt att den gulde åren där är den en ganska liten profil, kunde känna 30-40 tusen för ett enskilt inlägg.
Den är lite förbi idag för att det finns andra som är beredda att göra det ihop.
Sedan har vi också TikTok som växer så enormt fort och som inte är lika profilbaserat, utan det är mer innehållsstyrt.
Det är knappt såtialt mer egentligen, utan det ger en kreatörsplattform för att skapa innehåll.
Det skapar också en komplexitet i det här.
Det är en farlig fråga för att jag kan prata lite längre om just utvecklingen i branschen.
Men ska man försöka bryta ner det till vad vi gör då, för vi jobbar ju med reklam, det är kopplat in på den som marketing har.
Vad man kan säga egentligen är att tittar man tillbaka för tio år sedan, då var det väldigt produktfokuserad marknadsföring.
Så tenderar det alla medier, jag brukar säga att alla medier går lite i samma utveckling som mötes.
Sitter vi på TV-reklam på 90-talet och var den också ganska produktcentrerad.
Idag är den väldigt värdebaserad.
Tittar du på en Volvo-reklam idag så går man inte igenom bilens funktioner, utan det går igenom mycket känslor.
Vad är det för känslor du ska ha när du kör en Volvo till exempel.
Lite samma sak blir det med Influence for Marketing.
Tittar vi kanske tio år framåt i tiden så tror jag att man också har en liten av långsiktighet i hur man bygger in det.
Jag gillar det.
Hur upplever du att skalan över, alltså förtroendet för influencer som påverkats genom året, det känns också som att det har rört sig lite hit och dit.
Förr kunde man kanske säga att, ja men det här tror jag på, så trodde folk på det, nu vet jag inte om man tror på någon.
Nej jag tror att det har med lite att göra med vilka generationer han pratar med också och hur mycket influencers man följer.
Folk tenderar att komma ihåg de här skandalerna som medier gärna skriver om också, för det är klart att medier tar gärna upp det här, för det är också en konkurrent till deras business.
Sen är förtroendet någonting profiler och vi måste jobba med hela tiden.
Självklart är det så att jag har man precis varje enda samarbete som man kan fakturera för då tappar trovärdigheten.
Hela konceptet bygger ju på att du faktiskt kan stå för någonting.
Men jag tror att det mognar så pass bra och så pass fort att profiler klarar sig inte speciellt länge om man jobbar på det sättet idag.
Det kanske man har gjort för tio år sedan också lite av okunskap för att konceptet var nytt så att säga, eller nygammalt.
Det är ju inget nytt egentligen att folk går i god för produkter och tjänster medan konceptet är inplänsad och rakt in vad det gör alldeles ett nytt för tio år sedan.
Är det krångligt för er som byr och att, vad ska man säga, att en profil, jag förstår att du inte använder ordet bränd, men liksom, nu har den profilen jobbat med fyra olika varumärken.
Vi kanske inte kan, ni har en god relation med dem, ni gillar dem, ni vet att de levererar, men det blir liksom, vi kan inte gå in med mer varumärken i den här personen, utan de har liksom uppnått sin kvot så att ni måste dela till en nytt.
Är det ett problem liksom?
Alltså så kan det ju vara.
Det blir lättare och lättare i och med att det finns oerhört många kreatörer idag.
Men självklart är det så att man måste göra den analysen.
Ibland kan det ju vara okej att man har jobbat med flera varumärken i samma nisch för att man kanske är en modeprofil som kan pratar många olika typer av varumärken.
Går det däremot att du säger att det är lojal till alla storbanker så blir det en intressekonflikt.
Där har ju också bolagen lite grann, det är inte så många som pratar om det, men många bolag har också utnyttjat en faktum lite grann.
Man har gått in och köpt väldigt små volymer och väldigt många profiler för att blocka konkurrenter för samarbete.
Det är också något som ofta är speciellt.
Jag har med mig kanske lite yngre profiler också som tänker att de vill göra ett eller två inlägg här med mig för att testa om jag är bra.
Problemet är bara att gå bolag A in och jag har två inlägg där, då är det inte intressant för bolag B att jobba med den här profilen.
Och det vet ju bolaget.
Det är också det andra sidan av myntet.
Det finns kanske en rimlighet att kravställa viss långsiktighet från amassaden också.
Fan jag har aldrig tänkt på det så, men det är klart man kan göra så.
Det kanske vi borde börja med gå in och sponsra alla med typ en hantel och så vet de att de är bundna till oss nu.
Det var ju smart om man vill vara ett ärso.
Exakt om man vill vara ett ärso.
Sen tror jag också att man måste skilja idag lite grann på vad som är en influensstress och någon med stor påverkanskraft.
Vad som är en kreatör för att det finns väldigt många idag som bygger roligt innehåll.
Tar du med så får du en slitt på Youtube till exempel.
Det är ju underhållning man gillar att sitta på, så väljer man in kreativa koncept i det här.
Men det är kanske inte så att man går och köper just den här produkten för att de har sagt det.
Vilket är skillnad då om du har en profil som pratar om makeup till exempel, då är expert inom det området att då finns det ju en lite närmre resa till själva köpet.
Vart finns det liksom en gräns för att det ska bli lönsamt, för du nämnde här i början så pratade du litegrann om du sa always on och du sa något annat, om du sa liksom kampanjdrivet.
Alltså jag vet inte vad du använder för uttryck där men och vi har ju till exempel ingen sån här always on-grej, alltså att man alltid kör löpande hela tiden då, utan vi har ju gjort lite grejer ner för att vi tycker det är kul.
Så vi har ju kört dem med fördelslipp då som du nämner, det är väl därför du nämner dem.
Men sen om det blir någon lönsamhet i det eller om det får någonting, det vet vi liksom inte, det är för litet för att säga och jag har ingen aning, utan det är ju mer för att vi tycker dem är roliga, så vi tycker det är lite kul att jobba med dem och så har ju vi ofta gjort.
Så kan man liksom, när du sitter med ett bolag, hur snackar du med dem om, finns det liksom en mening att lägga ner en miljon på det här eller behöver man tänka, detta är någonting vi ska göra nu, från och med nu så är vi igång och vi kommer behöva plagiar detta under fyra år.
Alltså, vart drar man gränserna i det där och när blir det verksamt?
Det kan vara bra att backa lite till teorin, att om någon fick koppla dig till vad du sa där, vad ni har gjort med till exempel, för den slip, jag tycker att det var superkul att ni gjorde en sån grej, för att barmärket tar sig ut på ett väldigt kul och trovärdigt sätt.
Och någonstans förstår man ju när ni jobbar med dem att ni är seriös aktör, så är man inte jätteinsatt och så googlar man på hantlare till exempel, så hittar man er någonstans tidigt på Google, för ni jobbar säkert bra med er SEO.
Men tror man att det kommer hantlarna fram eller kommer de att ta med den pengar och sticka, och då vet man att har man sett er i olika sammanhang, där man har byggt lite social proof med kända kreatörer så bygger det en trovärdighet.
Den effekten har ju lite grann TV-reklam också med anledning att man vet att TV-reklam är dyrt, så förstår man att vilket bolag som helst kanske inte går in och investerar i TV, utan då har man en hyfsat seriös approach.
För att inte bara snacka om vårt eget medie.
Men när det kommer till investeringar och kronor tillbaka och så vidare, så måste man pågå in sig själv också, att implementationsmarknadsföring är ju inte en unik mirakelmetod, utan det är ju precis som alla andra marknadsföring, du måste ju tänka på hur ser man sig missfannad ut.
Vet folk vilka jag är för det första.
Vet folk vilket problem vi löser för dig.
Varför ska man gå allihop hos oss och inte våra konkurrenter?
Och någonstans bryta ner det där.
Man kommer aldrig ifrån att varumärket är viktigt.
Sen, precis som med alla andra kanaler, ibland kan man hitta superkommentering, man kan reajla ut sina produkter och sälja där det är sättet.
Men ett vanligt missförstånd är att man ofta tänker såhär, jag ska jobba med den här profilen och framförallt kanske inom e-handel också, för där har man en tendens att vara väldigt datadryven och Return on investment är liksom den heliga boken och det ska det ju vara men frågan är alltid över hur lång tid man pratar då.
Vad man ska se inför marketing som idag, tycker jag är ett sätt att skapa innehåll.
Då kan ni välja att ska vi skapa innehåll själva och säga att vi är bäst och tryggast och stärkare sektörer på marknaden eller ska vi hitta talspersoner som kan säga det här på ett trovärdigt sätt och på ett kanske lite mer underhållande och professionellt sätt.
Sen tar vi ut där kanaler där vår målgrupp finns.
Om du vill nå 70 plusare, då skulle du absolut inte pumpa ut massa TikTok-inhaler, utan det kanske ska synas på Facebook, det kanal ska synas på utomhusreklam.
Men den talar där till den här målgruppen på 70 plus och vilka litar de på?
Vi gör egentligen idag inga rena, sponsrade, organiska inlägg i profilernas kanaler.
Självklart lägger de upp där också för att nå sin kärnmålgruppen.
Allting boostas ut via meta-ads och spark-ads och det är inte alls ovanligt att vi tar ut våra koncepter i mer traditionell media också.
Det är där man pratar om influenser, drivet innehåll idag istället så att, och då är ibland influenser som är väldigt stärka påverkanskräftare, ibland skickliga kreatörer, men vi har väl egentligen tre leder då när det bygger reklam med profiler och det är att innehållet ska vara antingen underhållande eller inspirerande eller utbildande.
Är det något av de här tre eller fler så tycker det är att vi har lyckats då.
Jag fattar, okej jag har inte tänkt på det så men du ser det mer som att influensen då producerar materialet snarare än att det är reklamkanalen.
Är det någonting som är bundet av att förr så fick man ju ofta ganska stor organisk räckvidd, nu får man ju väldigt liten organisk räckvidd.
Såg ni på det på samma sätt för typ 7-8 år sedan?
Eller såg man det mer som att man använde deras kanaler för att nå ut då?
Vi har nog alltid sett emot för mycket på det här sättet.
Sen har de inte annars sören tänkt så, utan man har ofta tänkt att det här är en distributionskanal.
Vi får ofta fortfarande priser som frågar om CPI-n-priser och så vidare.
Det är en distributionskanal på ett sätt, men framförallt så är vi ju ett sätt att skapa innehåll.
Räckvig går att lösa på ganska många sätt och ganska kostnadseffektivt också.
Sen hänger vi den organiska räckvigden ihop lite grann med hur mycket pengar man pumpar in också i plattformens annonssystem.
Investerar du lite grann hos dem så är de också biologiserade med att dela lite innehåll organiskt.
Så det hänger ihop och där gör att det blir lite mer komplext i att det gäller inte bara att hitta en profil och bästa tiden att lägga upp på utan du behöver också en strategi hur du boostar det innehållet.
För oss som byråer, det är kanske man inte ska säga men det är bra för oss att det blir lite mer att tänka på också för att då kan vi göra mer nytta än att bara köra i den profilen.
Det är spännande.
Hur hittar ni rätt när ett bolag kommer till er?
Hur gör ni ur valet av människor eller av profiler?
Vad är det man kikar efter och hur ska man tänka där?
Deras har vi experter hos oss som i stort sett bara jobbar med att göra den här typen av matchengan.
Är deras jobb bara att sitta och scrolla flöden hela dagarna?
Är det ett jobb?
Inte riktigt så, men mycket så också.
Vi har såklart plattformar också som vi hjälper oss och verktyg för att vi effektivt ska sköna, navigera och framförallt önska av statistik.
För att en profil kan ju se väldigt bra ut när man tittar övergripande på ett konto, men statistiken måste också motsvara kundernas behov.
Det är väldigt olika valet för annonsörer.
Vissa vill jobba med ganska stor bredda profiler i målgrupper som är ganska lätta att hitta, medan vissa vill ha supernischade profiler och då får man gräva ännu djupare.
Sen är det så att, självklart har vi stenkoll på de marknader vi sitter i när vi gör research.
Till exempel Holland då, för bolag som vill nå konsumenter där, eller Tyskland.
Då får man jobba lite mer tekniskt med hur man hittar profilen.
Men vi hittar dem oftast och nästan alltid.
Sen får man göra också background-checken på dem.
Sen skiljer det lite när det är så att en profil ska göra tre, fyra sponsrar vi inläggs som ska boostas kontan att någon ska vara ambassadör, kanske långsiktigt för ett varumärke.
Då brukar det oftast boot ett möte så man får prata med profilen och se.
Så det här är ett drog i.
Vad är det mest utmanande i ditt jobb?
Vad är det som ger dig huvudvärk på dagarna?
Förutom personal, alltså i själva affärsmodellen?
Ja, precis.
Nu har vi ett superstark tid.
Du vet ju också att när man ska växa ett bolag så är det ju många aspekter att ta hävden till.
Men om man tänker på vår lösning och vårt erbudande, det är som alltid, man tror ju, när man sitter med det här, så tänker man att alla bolag har jobbat med influencers på ett eller annat sätt.
Men de stora bolagen, de vill väldigt gärna räkna sina investeringar i influencers marketing.
Det är liksom gemensamt varje gång jag träffar dem.
Men det finns ju stakeholders internt och det finns en rädsla för att saker ska gå fel, som kanske inte finns i andra kanaler.
För att de stora bolagen är vana att man går till en reklambyrå och skapar ett ignal och sen så köper man sig i sina distributionskanaler via sig mediebyrå.
Och egentligen är det inte någon större skingla på det vi gör, men det är klart att man läser mycket.
Det finns enormt mycket fördomar också kring vad influencers marketing är.
Som man kopplar det kanske till enbart handel om gamla sminkbloggar och sådär.
Och de fördomarna sitter kanske lite kvar.
Och det är klart att de beslutsfattare som sitter på de riktigt stora annonsbudgetarna, de är ju några år äldre också.
Samtidigt ser man att Miljunelevers VR går ut och säger att hälften av deras innehåll ska bestå av inpåsvenskadrivet innehåll.
Det rör sig lätt riktigt mycket.
Är det ni som får skit om någon, jag fattar att det händer väldigt sällan, men liksom, är det ni som har fått skit om någon profil helt plötsligt börjar, jag vet inte, gå och banänas och lägger ut massa skit och så ringer de er då och är arga för att ni inte har gjort någon bakgrundskoll?
Ja, så skulle det ju vara om jag inte hade gjort bakgrundskollen sedan.
Så är det ju så att det är också en stor fardel med att jobba just med en aktör som oss, att du ingår i ett avtal med oss och inte med de 40 profilen som du ska aktivera.
Och det glömmer många bort som gör det här själva.
Att sitta med 40 olika profilavtal istället för ett avtal med en som hanterar alla underkonsulter, det gör det ju hela väldigt mycket lättare då.
Jag köper det för jag är med i lite andra företag på udda sätt.
De jobbar ju tydligt med influencers och det här är ju alltid det stora problemet avtalsskrivningar och man ska förhandla om och det ska ändras och de följer inte vad de ska göra eller vad de gör till.
Det är ju ett jävla meck det där.
Ja och det är ju precis så, och det är ju egentligen en tjänst man köper av oss då.
Vi anlitar, det finns egentligen inget avtalsförhållande mellan hans hören och profiler, utan att avtalsförhållandet är med oss.
Så vi gör ett avtal med profilerna som under ett konsult.
Sen kommer man ju inte ifrån den faktorn att utav ett sätt så är det så att profilerna representerar varumärket och där har vi ett enormt ansvar i, så att vi sköter allting korrekt.
Idag är det väldigt sällan att det själva sponsrad inhållet blir fel för att det går alltid att vända hos legal avdelningar och marknadsavdelningar som godkända inhållet.
Sen är det klart att profilen i fråga kan göra någonting i det privata som smittar varumärket lite grann.
Sådana saker kan ju dyka upp men det tenderar att kanske inte bli lika stort som det var förr och då när det var så var det väldigt få profiler som var i ropet idag.
Det är ju en liten annan miljö med rörsida.
Hur gör ni för att inte jobba bort er själva?
Säg att ni sitter med ett företag och så har ni hjälpt dem under tre, fyra år och de kanske ändå försöker pusha igenom sin poäng så de kör ganska liknande upplägg och lite liknande profiler.
Vad är det som stoppar dem från att nu kapar vi United Influencers och nu kör vi själva?
Vad är era stora vallgrab?
Det måste vara lönsamt att jobba med oss.
Är det inte lönsamt att jobba med oss då ska man inte heller göra det.
Så egentligen är det inte så mycket svårare.
Sen är det ju så, i lönsamhetsbegreppet måste man också väga in tiden och kostnaderna man lägger på att göra det själv.
Men det är klart att så jobbar det med oss så ska det gå bättre än om du gör det här själv.
Det ser vi att det i regel gör, framför allt kanske också för att när du jobbar själv som varumärke då får du bara datan och insikten från dina egna samarbeten.
Vi har ju hundratals olika samarbeten där vi kan sända insikter från.
Det gör att vi ofta blir extremt effektiva än de som gör det här själva.
Sen är det klart att det finns en inhouse trend också även inom implementationsmarketing där vi pratar om bolag som kanske enbart lever på den typen av beledningar.
Då när det är lite svårare avvägning ska man ha en bio som gör det här eller så ska vi ha ett team på sexsju personer som gör det här internt istället.
Men då måste man också däcka lönar sociala avgifter för att det ska lämnas till dem.
Hur jobbigt är det att förhandla med influencers?
Jag tänker att det är lite grann som företagare som ska sälja sina bolag.
De tenderar att övervärdera sitt eget värde.
Av det lilla som jag har snackat med influencers så har de också en tendens att överskatta vad deras räckvidd är eller vad deras grej ska leda till.
Du blir såhär, jo men jobbar du med mig?
Jag verkligen brinner för det här.
Ja, det gör åtta andra miljoner också.
Det är svårt att...
Hur svårt är det för att ganska ofta blir väl era en dialog att försöka få dem att närma sig bolagets värdering eller?
Det är lite, och det är väldigt många olika scenarier när det kommer till förhandlingar och profiler.
För det första när du förhandlar, som i all förhandling, du måste vara beredd att gå ifrån bordet om du inte kan mötas på en rimlig nivå.
Det har jag underlättat för många andra SÖRA och för oss idag.
Kommer vi inte framåt med någon som vi tycker ligger o-ringligt i pris, då kan vi ofta hitta någon annan som kan göra det för en mer individ pris.
Sen är det inte vi där heller att vi ska hasla profilerna, utan de ska ju känna, precis som alla samtidigheterna, att jag får bra betalt och lotiverat till det här jobbet.
Sen finns det en stor massa som kanske kan tickas och vara dyrare, men om man jämför de mer traditionella produktionerna och reklam fortfarande är det extremt billigare.
Det är två läger där, vissa ligger högt men ändå lågt, prisvärt jämfört med många andra kanaler och andra sätt att skapa inlag.
Medan vissa såklart kanske lever kvar lite i tiden, att jag ska ha det, se och så mycket för att göra två inlägg.
Sen är det också så att för många profiler är det klart, det är svårt att bevisa sig om ett bolag köper kanske två inlägg på din Instagram och man har ganska begränsad budget för booster där inne.
Man kanske tänker att jag ska lägga 5 000 kronor på inlägg.
Vad är det inbryt att förvänta sig också då?
För mycket ligger också sanonshören själv, alltså har man jobbat med sitt varumärkande kanaler, hur går försäljningen generellt och på hur lång sikt utvärderar man det här?
Det är det jag måste ställa sig frågan om också för att du skulle aldrig köpa tre reklamspottar på tv4 och sedan tänka att bolaget ska vända sig på ner.
Men det finns ingen branschstandard kring hur man prissätter, reach eller engagemang eller något sånt där.
Den är inte lika uttalad som när du pratar till exempel CPI-npriser eller TRP-priser på tv och så vidare.
För att det är också ett skapande av innehållet som krympas ihop lite med den distributionen.
Sen är det så att majoriteten av distributionen idag kommer vid att vi boostar inläggande, diameter 1 och spark 1.
Där vet man väldigt noga vad som är bra priser för det räckvidd.
Där är den stora, stora fördelen när man jobbar med inför en så tydligt innehåll är att du oftast får en bättre stridning när du boostar innehållet än om du gör ett halvtråkigt inlägg som ingen egentligen kollar på.
Där kan man ju jämföra ganska mycket.
Sen är det ju så när det gäller innehållet.
Det handlar ju mycket om hur du professionellt vill ha innehållet.
Vill du ha ett ganska close-up innehåll som känns self-made som man säger, eller vill du ha det mer som en reglerat reklamfilm.
Där kan man nog säga att det skiljer sig fortfarande ganska mycket att bygga ett innehåll genom influencers kontron om du går till enare och större reklamberoare och ska göra samma sak.
Då är det plötsligt ganska billigt.
Vad är liksom de vanliga grejerna som du får rätta företag i när de kommer till er?
Alltså de har en tank i huvudet vad de vill åstadkomma eller vad de vill göra eller vad de förväntar sig.
Och så får du liksom säga, fan, sådär funkar det inte.
Så här funkar det.
Vad är liksom de vanliga felen vi som företag gör?
Jag tror att för det första så är det inte lika ofta längre man sitter i de dialogerna för fler och fler lär sig vilken roll infras marketing ska spela i deras mediamix.
Det är ett superstarkt förmedel att bygga både varumärk och försäljning, men man förstår ofta att försäljning är också en långsiktig strategi.
Det är slutprodukten av all marknadsförsörjning med det gör.
Sen är det klart att man träffar ofta entreprenörer och mindre bolag som kanske inte har råd att förlora, vilket man såklart har respekt för.
Och där får man ju också ha en dialog om att ska ni in och satsa 200 000 på det här om ni sen står med en tom kassa.
För jag kan inte lova att det får tillbaka pengarna i morgon på de här 200 000 kronorna, utan det måste finnas en viss långsiktighet där också.
Men då finns det ju massa intressanta upplägg i form av UGC, alltså Use-
and Reddit Content, där du jobbar med profiler som inte är så dyra, utan du kan få för ett par tusen mappar eller mindre för att du kan kunna bygga innehåll och tillvida sociala medier.
Så du behöver inte alltid jobba med en stor känd profil.
Det är en del som växer väldigt nykostås att man jobbar med UGC-kreatörer.
Där är man ganska van även som e-handlare att return investment på mina Facebook-annonser till exempel.
Det handlar mer om att bygga innehåll.
Hur långt är steget att gå från stora kända profiler till att gå till lite mindre UGC-kreatörer, till att helt plötsligt bara börja agenerera allt innehåll av sig själv?
Är det det ni ligger och sömnlösa på nätten över eller skiter ni i det?
Jag har hittills inte legat sömnlös över det.
De flesta jobbar också i ett brett spann.
Man har profiler som kanske bär varumärket, som har lite mer kända ansikte.
Man har UGC-profiler som kan bygga mycket innehåll i den här bulken för att visa hur produkter och tjänster faktiskt funkar.
Men profilerna i regel stärker varumärket lite grann.
UGC ligger lite närmare köptillfället.
Stora profiler ligger ofta lite närmare än varumärkesbyggande strategi.
Men när det kommer till AI och nr 1-0, det är svårt att säga det här.
Jag tror att just att dencitetet är ganska viktigt när det kommer till profiler.
Du är inne på frågan själv, vad kan man lita på och inte?
Då behöver man så för att ta fram en AI-profil som också har byggt en viss, lite personligt varumärke också.
Annars faller det lite på att man kanske har svårt att bygga social proof genom någon som inte finns på riktigt och som helt enkelt är fäkt.
Sen finns det en annan aspekt som jag också var inne på tidigare.
Är det bara så att du vill bygga ett underhållande upplägg, alltså en kul, reklam anfäng, då spelar det kanske en stor roll om det är AI eller om det är på riktigt.
Men tror du att vi rör oss mot en ännu mer cynisk värld?
Det kommer givetvis att komma företag som använder aktörer och bara skapar filmer om dem.
Vi har ju sett att, är det Nelly som är i någon stämning mot, nu kommer jag inte ihåg om det är Kin eller, det är väl Kin tror jag, där de väl har tagit deras bilder och haft på sin site som sittmärke.
Jag tror att det är såhär med lite disclaimer på det.
Det kommer givetvis komma aktörer som tar kända profiler, lägger in sin produkt i deras händer och bara gör marknadsföring.
Någonstans om vi drar ut det på några års sikt så kommer det givetvis göra att vi som människor blir, nej det tror jag inte på eller liksom såhär, det där är liksom inte rimligt.
Att vi måste börja hitta nya sätt att bygga förtroende.
Var tror du att förtroende i kapitalet tar vägen?
Vad är rätt värde att bygga förtroende i?
Det är ju nästan ett avsnitt i sig men man ska försöka byta ner det.
För det skiljer till samma sak som diskussioner som var mycket i jula kring AI-musik.
Är den bra eller inte bra?
Det låter ju jättebra.
Men det finns stor känsla när de flesta får reda på att den här låter inte är på riktigt och tappar känslan för det.
Vi ser också stor skillnad på när man pratar lokal marknadsföring och global marknadsföring.
Tittar man lokalt i Sverige eller Norden idag så har det varit svårt att kanske bara skäla något ansikte och sedan köra på utan att få en ganska tung stämning.
Tittar man ur ett globalt perspektiv, om man kollar de här giganterna så kanske man inte har samma moral.
Jag vågar inte riktigt svara på just den frågan och tro om framtiden där, men man får ju någonstans ändå lita på att autenticiteten blir liktigare ju större bristfarare det här.
Hur kommer det att påverka annonsörer?
Vart är annonseringsvärlden på väg?
Är det att kommer man gå mer mot gammelmedia eller kommer man gå mer mot att it vi kör på, vi ska finnas i varenda jävla kanal för att det viktiga är att synas och höras och så att folk bränner in bilden av varumärket eller har du nån känsla för vart du tror att det kommer att påverka annonsering?
Jag tror man hela tiden tänker att världen ska vädlas upp och ner men tittar man lite tillbaka i tiden så är det såhär, det har inte hänt så där fruktansvärt mycket egentligen utan det är klart att som varumärkemot så måste du anpassa dig till vad din publik finns.
Om ingen läser dagstidningar längre då hur effektivt det är med det att den må vara eller har varit historiskt så blir det inte så effektivt att vara där om ingen läser tidningen.
Det är det ena.
Sen är det också så här, olika medier bygger också olika möjligheter till hur kreativ man kan vara.
Det ser vi med TikTok till exempel, att man kan en ensam person från sitt vardagsrum göra att superkreativt och coolt som två-tre månader hos reklambyrån att göra för.
Så klart saker och ting går väldigt mycket fortare men hur det är där man ska bränna in sitt varumärke hos sina konsumenter eller om man vill vara lite coolare och lite mer kreativt, det är egentligen också olika strategier.
De strategierna kommer nog att finnas, vi ser fortfarande idag att mellan klockan 9 och 11, som nyhetsmorgontiden, och vad som brukar komma efter nyhetsmorgon, där finns det några varumärkena som kör tre spotta varje paus för att se till att ingen älskar glömma bort det här varumärket.
Man kanske kör reklamen på radio också med sina jinglar som man har gjort i 20 år.
Medan det finns de här som är väldigt low-key i sin marknadsföringsrätt.
Jag tror att det handlar lite om att sådär kommer det säkert alltid att vara.
Vissa varumärken bygger sin strategi på att vara ganska på, medan vissa inte är det.
Finns det någonting som är viktigast?
Förut nämnde du till exempel de här tre tumreglerna du hade.
Det skulle vara inspirerande eller underhållande.
Du sa något sådant i alla fall, tre olika.
Men när man som företag börjar ge sig ut eller man tänker att man ska göra det här på riktigt.
Jag tycker ofta när man lyssnar på folk som pratar om marknadsföring så pratar de väldigt ofta om vad som funkar eller ger spridning.
Det är inte samma sak som att ge konvertering eller att det ger rätt känsla hos kunden.
Då kanske man pratar att det var för ett tag som var det viktigt att man gjorde grundarannonser.
Man stod och pratade om sitt företag och sen skulle man göra vissa hookar på ett visst sätt.
Men bygger ni någon sorts ramverk kring att man först behöver bygga ett förtroende, sen behöver man bygga ett intresse, sen behöver man bygga en så att det blir mer köpfokuserat.
Tänker man så kring kampanjer och åratal av jobb eller handlar det mer bara om att existera i det mediumet där folk finns?
Det där är superviktigt, vilken ordning man gör, och jag tror framförallt, om jag tittade tillbaka för tio år sen när det kändes som det växte raketdatat och folk kunde starta ganska stora ihandlar från sin vardagsrum, då ville man ju ofta först få in pengarna via försäljning och sen bygga varumärket.
Ofta är det saker i sin linda, det var lite samma sak när influensormarktingen var ritta, men då var det ganska lätt att tjäna bra pengar och få bra konvertering på det.
Men ju mer det mognar desto mer måste man tänka lite långsiktigt också.
Vad vi gör med de större annonsörerna är att koppla på tredjepartsanalyser och marknadsundersökningar, till exempel via NEPA, för att se hur måldruppen har tagit emot den här satsningen som vi har gjort för er.
Så det är ju de bitarna också.
Men tillbaka till en fråga med att bygga varumärkare och varumärkare och så vidare, det gör vi via profiler.
Vi rekommenderar aldrig att du köper ett inlägg och sen försöker du kränga produkter.
Först när du gör den profilen.
Först kanske man ska prata lite om att jag har ett problem.
Steg två, jag har hittat lösningen på mitt problem.
Steg tre, hur funkar den lösningen?
Steg fyra, rekommenderar att testa det här, det har varit skitbra.
Steg fem, nu har jag ett erbjudande tre också om det är så man ska ha på.
För att förenkla lite grann, man gammar lite grann med grunden i egentligen vad man sitt företag går ut på.
Man finns i till för att lösa sina kundesproblem, det är nästan grunden i allt företagande.
Jag fattar.
Jakob, jag känner att det är ett, jag brukar säga att det finns vissa avsnitt som är för mig och så finns det vissa avsnitt som är för de som lyssnar.
Det här var ett väldigt joeligt avsnitt.
Det var kul att få höra lite grann om hur den här världen funkar.
Stort tack för att du tog ditt tid då med mig.
Ja men tusen tack.
Jag har aldrig tänkt på det så, men det är klart man kan göra så.
Det kanske vi borde börja med, gå in och sponsra alla med en hantel och så vet de att de är bundna till oss nu.
Det var ju smart, om man vill vara ett asshole.